[Music]
since coming to power mr. Trump has
tweeted over 2,000 times often insulting
people and bragging with a liberal use
of exclamation marks
[Music]
he's played golf 88 times held very long
handshakes and created a new word called
fufu as well as a new country number but
mr. Trump's presence in the White House
is no joke his first year in office has
been marred by an investigation into his
dealings with Russia his handling of
white supremacists and a war of words
with North Korea's supreme leader kim
jong-in but has he achieved his promise
of making America great again when he
took office mr. Trump set about signing
a number of executive orders and
memoranda such as backing out of the
trans-pacific partnership the world's
largest regional free trade agreement
and building a wall on the country's
southern border with Mexico although
this has yet to happen
mr. Trump has signed 58 executive orders
many more than mr. Obama after his first
year but he's failed to enact most of
his big campaign promises except for his
tax reform bill and the declaration of
Jerusalem as Israel's capital the
American economy has continued to grow
strongly under mr. Trump unemployment is
lower than it's been for more than a
decade continuing the trend that was
started during mr. Obama's presidency
after the 2008 recession the president
deserves some of the credit for the low
unemployment rate but in reality he's
been in the right place at the right
time he has pulled America out of the
Paris Accord on climate change and
undermined the Iranian nuclear deal but
he hasn't quit NATO as many feared all
started any Wars he has undermined
universal values such as democracy and
him rights mr. Trump's presence in the
White House has divided America and his
approval rating of 37% is the lowest of
any recent president one year into their
time
you